all right we got the Serpent's pass here
and again and I'm actually really happy
I was talking about this just the last
few log I was saying I really hope they
don't just leave it where Ang's like oh
oh oh I go through pain in this one
episode and then yeah I'll get over it
then the next I like that it's still
carrying over and now you we got a
different stage of grief going on here
and I really like that I like that he's
trying to be stronger and he's trying to
sort of keep the emotion out and you can
understand that he doesn't want it to
hurt anything so make him a stronger
leader and he's trying to be he's trying
to be tougher so it's it it seemed very
logical to go this route which I really
enjoy but on top of that we get some
other cool stuff going on we got this
this cool thing that they have to cross
over called the Serpent's pass which is
a bunch of rocks that go across the
water here that I guess it kind of looks
like a serpent but that's not why it got
its name anyway it's more because there
actually is a giant serpent that attacks
them one of the few designs I didn't
care for I didn't think the dragon snake
whatever that is I didn't think it was
all that interesting
I've seen buried designs but anyway so
you got Sokka comes across the hump like
on an a I'm sure I saw her on the know
her because I mean look at that picture
she's gonna be coming back I'm sure so
I'll get her name then I just caught a
warrior girl for now um but she comes
back and which is good as obvious when
he was asking about her I think what the
other episodes I guess so how she doing
and oh she's not here okay so obviously
they're building that up and what I like
kind of obvious but still I think works
is that you have an going through his
despair and sends not wanting to give in
to his emotions not wanting to get
attached because he's afraid he'll
really get hurt again yeah Sokka going
through the same thing because he lost
the princess character and you really he
doesn't want to quite give in to this
character either because he's afraid
of losing someone they'll get that close
to him again so again it's a good good
parallel there and there's another
parallel going on I like that now Jed
has entered back into this who I did not
I didn't think was one of the more
interesting characters and I will admit
it looks like Zuko and him were kind of
teaming up and jet figures out who he is
like one of the few people figures out
who he is come on nobody can put
together this kid and his chubby old
uncle and the kid as this giant flaming
burn side of his face that this is the
Prince but annum
but Jed figures it out they seem to form
this friendship I'm if they want to stay
consistent I would think that Jets
probably gonna betray him because I
remember that's what got him in trouble
before it was his hatred of the fire
tribe and just never wanting to show any
sympathy so now he has like the prince
and he's tried to befriend him it looks
like Zuko is sort of giving in I'm
actually sir hoping they go that route
again cuz just anything to crap on Zuko
it's it's so sick of me but it's like it
just makes him somewhat for interesting
the more he can fight through that stuff
the more I'm like yeah go Zuko fight
through it turn to the good side or
whatever so um I'm just a really
demented bastard that way I guess uh so
or maybe they'll form a perfectly nice
friendship who knows uh so you got them
going on this trip you got these two
parallels going on and finally at the
very end
katara says it's okay to sort of give in
to this and how do they how does he
finally give in he sees a baby paying
for it okay I I'm not gonna say like
seeing a baby being born isn't gonna
like change everything it's a totally
legit thing just know couldn't you think
of something else it just seems like
that's the most sort of generic thing
you could go for it but I don't know
that it's it I don't know
lots of people have their lives changed
when they see you know their child or
just a child being born so I mean that's
that that's perfectly cool um and I like
that he's come to a point in that he
realizes it's he can let the emotion in
he he can accept that this is some he's
gonna fight for and that's the exact
balance he needs when he gets to the
location he sees this giant drill that's
being made I'm not sure if he was going
to attack or whatever but he says pretty
much at the end Appa he's gonna have to
wait and I like that I like that it's
only when he let the emotions in that he
could come to that very rational
conclusion so I thought that was good
that was a good evolution there that
that was a good journey uh and I'm
trying to think what else
it looks like the warrior girl is
heading back now I sort of thought again
maybe that's another character joining
or something but I guess not an image
will pop up again um again I mean just
it sure she'll pop up again so yeah I'm
trying what else to say about this
episode it's it's funny seeing Zuko get
upset uh about something as small as
just wanting better food on the boat um
and him sir I think it's not fair so
there sir like just this mini little
debate that's like oh we deserve better
than this we deserve you know what the
people up there are getting and it's
it's such a tiny thing but you can see
that happening you can see them saying
this is worth going to the risk of
getting caught and being thrown off the
boat because we we deserve it we're
fighters we we deserve the same
treatment or if not better so I like
that but that was actually a good I do
sort of like the connection him and Jed
are making um I do sir hope Jett becomes
a more interesting character because I
guess he he did do much for me but it
wasn't awful just just didn't grab me
that much but like I say it's an
interesting team up it'll be very
fascinating where that goes I
again the zig farm is just like I hope
you betrays him but it's like that
how mean is that um it just makes good
drama so we'll see where that goes and
especially is now that Zuko's opening up
like I might be good to trust somebody
it might be good to have people on my
side man 1 that'd be great of jet just
like totally backstabs of event circles
like I do it I can't trust anyone and
the lightning strikes again and the tear
goes is like father it's just I I love
the big epic like that I just
love it um or maybe they'll make a
really really good partnership and
they'll be like the most awesome badass
duo ever like I said the show is good
enough that's good at throwing surprises
at you so it'll be interesting to see
where that goes um yeah I can't think of
a too much actually I will say the
cabbage guy is trying to make me laugh a
bit cuz I saw this cabbage guy and they
popped up a second time I'm like ok it
didn't really make me laugh either time
but then everyone's talking like the
cabbage guy the cabbage guy I'm like
what is the I'm sure he'll show up again
but I mean I'm still not getting the
comedy at it he is starting to get a
little bit of a laugh at you just make
it bounce make me laugh a little bit um
it's just such a bizarre running joke
why is this guy so obsessed with his
cabbage focus focus serve a bet um you
know just why is this guy so obsessed
with his cabbages and why does I don't
know why is he keep showing up in all
these places is it even in maybe it's
like his 1 we have a bajillion twins or
something I don't know maybe he's a spy
wouldn't that be a great twist like he
was a gs5 than the Holt I like the
world's greatest spy is do these
disguise as a cabbage salesman so I
don't know it's it's growing on me I
used to not do much for me but it's like
the foamy mouth guy in Reverse for the
foamy mouth guy was phenomenal that one
time and then the next time so yeah sir
faded here's a joke that kind of it
didn't start out that hot now it's like
it's starting to get a little funny
that's I think Garfield always said
that's the definition of a running joke
start off with a joke that's not the
least bit funny but actually gets
funnier the more and more you do it so
then maybe that's the case here but
we're going this a good episode I'm
curious to see what they're gonna do
with that big badass drill so um yeah
that's about it see you in the next one